Here was the answer for this one. Amazing effort if you got both of these
correct. Now this one was tricky since there was a simplification that you had
to do at the end. let's see if you got it. let's start by thinking what we want
our denominator to be in order to simplify. We want each of these powers to be
a multiple of 6. So that way, they can be divided by 6. We'll want the powers
of 2, x and y to be divisible by 6 since that's our index of the root. So we
want to change to the 1 into 2 to the 6 x squared into x to the 6th and y to
the 8th into y to the 12th. This means we have to multiply the denominator by
the 6th root of 2 to the 5th x to the 4th and y to the 4th. These are the
missing factors we need, to increase each of these powers to these powers. We
want to multiply by a form of 1, so we multiply our numerator by the same
expression as this denominator. Next we multiply 4 times this radical to get
our new numerator. We simply our denominator by writing 2xy squared. It's the
6th root of each of these factors. Our numerator can't be simplified. Since
each of these powers is not divisible by 6. So we just rewrite 2 to the 5th as
32. We have a common factor of 2 in our numerator and our denominator so we can
simplify. This leaves us with our final answer. Great work with your factors
and radicals if you got this far.